So, da bin ich wieder. Weiter geht's.
Genau dort, wo wir gestern aufgehört haben.
Ich hab noch keine 2 Minuten irgendwie zwischendurch weitergespielt.
Muss mal kurz gucken.
Ja ne, passt. Bisschen höhere Bitrate muss sein, sonst pixelt das so.
Moin. Also, heute spielen wir noch ein bisschen Baldur's Gate 3 weiter.
Bzw. Baldur's Gate 4.
Ich hab mir gedacht, ich nenn den Streamtitel einfach mal so, weil das heute der 4. Stream ist, wo ich das Game schon gespielt hab.
Am Wochenende basteln wir wieder was. Wir haben ja auch schon was ausgedacht.
Und ich muss vor allem mein Video endlich hochladen.
Ich hab ja schon längst ein neues Video aufgenommen, ich hab bloß noch keinerlei Gameplay drunter.
Und ich hab noch nix dran geschnitten und kein Thumbnail und nix.
Ich muss das Video hochladen. Das muss ich unbedingt morgen machen. Irgendwann.
Dass das dann quasi so ab, keine Ahnung, 12 Uhr oder so, morgen Nachmittag oder so on geht.
Und dann basteln wir im Stream wieder irgendwas.
Bin mir noch nicht ganz sicher, was. Vielleicht machen wir auch was aus der nicht so, sonderlich kurzen To-Do-Liste.
War auch nicht verkehrt. Müssen wir das mal auch langsam abarbeiten.
Aber heute, ich hab übelst Bock, Baldur's Gate 3 weiterzuspielen.
Und nachdem ja sogar einige gefragt haben, wann geht's weiter. Was ich echt cool finde.
Bei den Streams sind jetzt nicht so viele dabei.
Erstens ist das, glaube ich, kein Game, wo man jetzt...
Es gibt bestimmt... Also, der muss halt den Typ Game mögen, ja.
Das ist kein Battle Royale Game oder so zum Zugucken, wo permanent irgendwas ist.
Also ich weiß, dass nicht so viele zugucken wie bei den anderen Streams.
Aber, wenn ich die Auswahl habe zwischen offline hocken und weiterspielen.
Oder ein paar Leute finden's nice und ich kann das im Stream spielen, das ist doch viel besser.
Wenn man beides combined.
Ich hatte übrigens gestern... Ja, nee, vorgestern.
Ich hatte vorgestern auch einen Termin mit meinem Chef.
Und sie haben gesagt, Max, deine Probezeit ist ja bald um.
Und da hab ich gesagt, ja, ich weiß, meine Probezeit ist bald um.
Und dann hat er gesagt, Max, weißt du was? Wir wollen, dass du da bleibst.
Hab ich gesagt, okay, ich will auch, dass ich da bleib.
Und ich will auch da bleiben.
Also scheinen wir uns da schon mal einig zu sein.
Musste auch erst mal... Okay, ein paar Sachen...
Ich mein, da kommt man aber nicht drumherum, ja?
So ein paar Sachen hab ich natürlich schon ein bisschen verkackt.
So die ersten... Gerade die ersten paar Wochen.
Ich hab mich beispielsweise schon auf Produktivsystem eingeloggt.
Ohne, dass ich ein Ticket dafür hatte, ging gleich eine Meldung auf.
Das ist alles super restrictive da.
Ich hab mir in der Cloud eine Achtkernkiste angelegt mit 32 Gramm.
Hab mir dann halt gedacht, okay, wen juckt's, dass das Ding 250 Euro im Monat kostet?
Hat anscheinend doch jemand gejuckt, dass es 250 Euro im Monat kostet.
Aber hey, ich mein, ich hab mir nicht einfach just for fun eine Achtkernkiste in der Cloud angelegt,
weil ich da gerade Bock drauf hatte.
Ich hab mir eine Achtkernkiste mit 32 Gramm in der Cloud angelegt,
weil ich öfters Docker-Images bauen muss und irgendwie sonst eine halbe Stunde brauche,
bis das alles gepullt und gepusht ist.
Da hab ich mir gedacht, komm, weißt du was?
Mach eine fette Kiste.
Ja, also das ist echt so ein Ding, muss ich sagen.
Weiß nicht, ob ich mich da dran gewöhnen kann.
Also, wie gesagt, ich bin ja bei einer Versicherung und die haben übelst Geld.
Aber sind teilweise, wir können ja sagen, von nix kommt nix, ne,
aber die sind teilweise übelst pingelig, was Geld angeht.
Da kam doch ernsthaft jemand auf die Idee, irgendwie so einen 2-Cluster-Kubernetes,
äh, 2-Node-Kubernetes-Cluster vorzuschlagen.
Ach, lass uns den doch lieber abbauen für Kostenersparnis.
Das kostet, keine Ahnung, 35 Euro im Monat oder sowas mit den kleinen E2-Nodes.
Wo ich mir denke, das wäre mir die Mühe nicht mal wert.
Da kostet das Warten, wenn man ihn doch mal braucht,
mehr als den einfach mal drei Monate am Stück ohne Usage durchlaufen zu lassen.
Also, keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß nicht.
Also Leute, wir sind übrigens genau da stehen geblieben, wo wir gestern aufgehört haben.
Wollen wir gleich weiter.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Und die bezahlen auch tausende Euro.
Okay, in dem Fall ist es an Microsoft und an Google.
Und ein bisschen an Amazon, aber hauptsächlich an Microsoft und Google.
Bezahlen die auch unglaublich viel Geld.
Aber dann haben sie irgendwie Probleme wegen 35 Euro.
Auch witzig, wir haben letztens 10.000 Euro.
Ich glaube, das habe ich sogar schon erzählt.
Wir haben knapp 10.000 Euro Traffic-Kosten produziert aus Versehen letztens.
Ja, aber da beschwert sich natürlich keiner drüber.
10.000 Euro Traffic.
Joa, kommt halt mal vor, ne.
Aber 35 Euro im Monat für einen Cluster.
Nee.
Das geht, das geht nicht.
Das können wir nicht machen.
Aber 10.000 Euro Traffic, das ist okay.
Seems good.
Kriege haben die gemacht.
Kriege.
Keine Ahnung.
So ganz habe ich die Taktik noch nicht verstanden.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, das sind komplett unterschiedliche Kostenstellen.
Das eine juckt den anderen überhaupt nicht.
Außerdem, die haben genug Geld.
Es ist nicht so, als hätten die keine Kohle, ey.
Die schwimmen, naja, vielleicht nicht übertrieben, aber die schwimmen im Geld.
Aber auf der anderen Seite, wie gesagt, von nix kommt nix.
Vielleicht musst du ein bisschen knauserig sein.
Ich sag ja auch, der Weg, um reich zu werden, ist mehr Geld zu behalten, als auszugeben.
Pfeifert, komm in die Koppe.
Ich glaube, ich sollte auch nach Dubai.
Oder Dubai, wie die Amis immer sagen.
Dubai.
Echt krasser Finanz-Training-Influencer.
Wobei, nee, nee, nee, Moment.
Moment.
Das geht ja nicht.
Ich muss ja demnächst schon Fitness-Influencer werden.
Ich hab übrigens, Leute.
Ich bin fast, ich bin fast bei unter sieben Minuten für, ähm.
Also, Fachsinn.
Ich muss den Satz nochmal neu anfangen.
Ich bin fast bei unter sieben Minuten im Durchschnitt pro Kilometer
bei einer Strecke von, also fast unter sieben Minuten
bei einer Strecke von so 6,3 Kilometer, die ich immer renne.
Das finde ich eigentlich ganz nice.
Für das, dass ich erst vor, frag mich nicht, drei Wochen oder so angefangen habe,
regelmäßig, regelmäßig zu rennen.
Finde ich das eigentlich ganz gut.
Ich denke, daran sieht man auch, dass, dass
vorher, ich hab mich ja, ich bin ja vorher schon immer so eine
eineinhalb, zwei Stunden wandern gegangen.
Halt auch relativ zackig, dass das schon was gebracht hat.
Am Anfang war es halt super anstrengend, weil ich halt null Muskeln hatte, was das angeht.
Aber es geht immer besser.
Wie gesagt, und seit ich die neuen Schuhe hab, ist es tatsächlich sogar ganz angenehm.
Das weiteste, was ich bisher gerannt bin, war knapp 8 Kilometer, irgendwie 7,85 oder sowas.
Da war ich schon ziemlich, da war ich schon ziemlich im Arsch danach.
Allerdings nicht so sehr kreislaufmäßig im Arsch, sondern
hauptsächlich haben mir übelst meine, meine Knie und
die, wie nennt man das so?
Wie nennt man den Teil vom Fuß, wenn man den Fuß bisschen umknickt,
wo es dann an der Seite zieht, so Sehnen oder sowas, Bänder, Sehnen, so.
Die haben, die haben ziemlich gezogen, so, wenn ich den Fuß nicht ganz gerade hatte.
Also, ich glaube, ich glaube, mit 10 Kilometer rennen sollte ich vielleicht noch ein bisschen warten, bis ich ein bisschen geübter bin.
Nun gut.
Lange Rede, kurzer Sinn.
Wir wollten eigentlich weiterspielen, dort, wo ich gestern aufgehört hab.
Gesehen gestern, paar neue Leute gefollowed, paar alte Leute direkt unsubscribed, unfollowed.
Die wollten keinen Gaming-Content sehen.
Aber ganz im Ernst, ich mein, ab und zu mal ein bisschen was spielen, vor allem unter Anbetracht der Tatsache,
dass ich ja eigentlich mal als Gaming-Youtuber angefangen hab, sollte, sollte doch erlaubt sein.
Auf der anderen Seite umso mehr freut es mich, dass ihr am Start seid und,
dass wenn ihr übrigens noch nicht gefollowed habt, würde ich mich auch sehr drüber freuen.
Und, dass sogar Leute geschrieben haben, alter Max, wie sieht es aus, wann geht es weiter mit Baldur's Gate 3?
Das fand ich nice.
Und ich hätte heute eh weitergespielt und halt einfach ohne streamen.
Sebasu-Chan, 95.
Voll gut.
Ayaya.
Ach Leute, jetzt wo wir grad beim Thema Ayaya sind.
Moin Kyuukun, danke für den Sub, 32 Monate.
Ich hab, ich hab tatsächlich meinen dritten Anime geguckt letztens.
Voll live, so.
Ich bin nicht der große Anime-Gocker.
Wobei, vielleicht sind es auch schon fünf gewesen oder so.
Beziehungsweise die zweite, die zweite Season.
Die zweite Season von der Serie.
Und, ähm, ich kann das nicht aussprechen.
Ich glaub auf, auf Englisch heißt das Jobless Reincarnation oder sowas.
Da hab ich schon, da hab ich schon die erste Season geguckt.
Muss sagen, das hat mich doch erstmal sehr verwirrt.
Ich dachte, das ist so eine 0815-Fantasy-Story.
Aber, also, so ein paar Einschübe dazwischen waren nicht so 0815-Fantasy.
Ja, genau, und da läuft grad die zweite Season.
Ich hab jetzt die ersten acht Folgen geguckt.
Die gehen ja nicht lang. Die gehen ja nur 25 Minuten.
Ähm, also, ich kann das nicht aussprechen.
die ersten 8 Folgen geguckt. Die gehen ja nicht lang, die gehen ja nur 25 Minuten.
Ja.
So, aber.
Weiter geht's.
BG3.
Ne.
Das ist OBS, das ist nicht Baldur's Gate 3.
Das ist Baldur's Gate 3.
So, also Leute.
Wer gestern nicht dabei war, ich erzähl das nochmal kurz.
Ich bin Mitte, Mitte Akt 2.
Gerade in einem Dungeon.
Ich hab ungefähr 70 Stunden in dem Game.
Bis jetzt.
Ich spiel auf schwer.
Wobei ich sagen muss, es ist wirklich nicht schwer.
Und wir sind stehen geblieben hier mitten, mitten in dem Dungeon.
Und haben gerade hier ganz viele, wie ihr seht.
Die haben hier gestern alle gebashed.
Ganz viele Gegner um die Ecke gebracht.
Ich würd sagen, achja.
Und danach ging hier hinten der Raum auf.
Und da sind noch mehr Gegner und...
Und irgendein Boss oder was auch immer das ist.
Aber, nachdem der ganze Fight hier ultra close gewesen ist.
Weil ich zu blöde war.
Und ich den Fight komplett falsch angefangen hab.
Keine Spell Slots mehr.
Ein Spell Slot noch.
Und, und, ja okay.
Warlocks haben immer Spells.
Mit kurzer Rast.
Also, ich, ich, ich, ich loot die jetzt mal.
Und dann geh ich ins Lager.
Ich hoffe, da ist irgendwas Gescheites dabei bei denen hier.
Ich geh jetzt mal ins Lager.
Hab ich den Eindruck, dass der Sound heute lauter ist als gestern?
Oder ist das einfach wieder Windows Pepega Shit?
Leute, ich bin heute auf der Arbeit so ausgeflippt mit Windows wieder.
Das macht mich fertig.
Und zwar, also, ihr müsst euch das mal vorstellen.
Wir haben eine SQL Datenbank aufgebaut in der Cloud.
Ist ja an sich jetzt nicht so super...
...ein was?
Moment.
Moin zusammen.
Hatte gestern noch ein witziges Erlebnis.
Mein uralt Gamex-Adress ist wohl in irgendeinem Spam-Skript gelandet.
Mit Urwohn-Massenhaft-Konten erstellt.
Und ich krieg jetzt 100.000 Newsletter.
Hat jemand sowas schon mal erlebt?
Ne.
Hab ich noch nicht erlebt.
Ja.
Also, was ich erzählen wollte.
Und zwar, wir haben eine SQL Datenbank in der Cloud gebaut.
Bei Google.
Und...
Ich mein, die soll natürlich von der Software benutzt werden.
Ist klar.
Und irgendwann haben wir...
Also, wir haben das mit Terraform aufgebaut.
Und das...
Und die Software hat sich einfach ums Verrecken nicht installieren lassen.
Die konnte immer nix anlegen in der Datenbank.
Bis wir dann drauf gekommen sind.
Okay.
Dieses komische Terraform-Modul, das da einer gebaut hat.
Das macht irgendwelche Magic-Sachen.
In...
In der Datenbank, nachdem die erstellt wurde.
Und der hat Sündagsfehler drin.
Und jedes Mal...
Wenn jetzt versucht wird, in der Datenbank was zu machen.
Wird diese...
Wird diese Function aufgerufen.
Also, jedes Mal, wenn eine Tabelle...
Äh, jedes Mal, wenn eine Datenbank erstellt wird.
Wird diese Function aufgerufen.
Und die Sündagsfehler hatten das Tabellen erstellen kackt ab.
Äh, das Datenbank erstellen kackt ab.
Und...
Jetzt hab ich vergessen, worauf ich eigentlich...
Worauf ich...
Worauf ich eigentlich raus wollte.
Ja.
Ach ja, genau.
Und das hat mich so aufgeregt.
Windows.
Kack...
Kack Windows.
Jetzt weiß ich, worauf ich raus wollte.
Genau.
Kack...
Kack-Triple-U-Windows.
Und zwar...
Ich hab mir dann...
Den Source-Code von dieser...
Store-Procedure oder...
Datenbank-Function.
Oder was das genau war.
Hab ich mir gezogen.
Das waren irgendwie...
120 Zeilen wildes SQL.
Ey, Hiko-San.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Bei dem Namen fällt mir nur ein.
So, zumindest...
Hab ich dann...
Hab ich mir den...
Den Source-Code von dieser...
120...
120 Zeilen...
Wildes...
Wildestes SQL gezogen.
Und dacht mir, weißt was?
Du fixst jetzt einfach den Syntax-Fehler da drin.
Da haben ein paar Anführungszeichen gefehlt.
Und dann appliest du das.
Und dann ist gut.
So, und jetzt...
Jetzt...
Damit man das applyen kann.
Muss man das über...
Über einen Container machen und so.
Leute.
Ich sag euch.
Ich wollte das über Windows-Copy-Pasten.
Und ich hatte...
Jedes Mal...
Sonderzeichen drinnen in meinem Editor.
Nachdem ich's copy und pastet hab.
Ich hab 140 Zeilen copy-pastet.
Terminal aufgemacht.
Vim aufgemacht.
Set-Paste.
Reingepastet.
Sonderzeichen drin gehabt.
Gelöscht.
Nochmal prob...
Sonderzeichen drin gehabt.
Es...
Es ging einfach nicht.
Ich bin komplett ausgerastet.
Windows ist...
Der letzte Scheiß, was das angeht.
So ein Schrott-System, Alter.
So, und am Ende hat's dann...
Hat's dann hingehauen.
Nachdem ich mir über den SSH-Tunnel das Git-Repo geklont hab.
Und alles hinkopiert habe.
Anstatt es zu copy-pasten.
Dann...
Dann ging's.
Aber...
Ganz wilder Shit, Alter.
Ich sollte jetzt mal gucken.
Hab ich jetzt eigentlich alles gelootet?
Kann das sein?
Das...
Jetzt mal...
Ich hab jetzt zu viel geschwätzt.
Ich hab jetzt gar nicht hier richtig...
Richtig hing...
Aber hier ist nirgendwo was dabei gewesen.
Nachdem ich gelootet hab.
Und ich will erst mal ins Lager...
Be...
Bevor ich...
Will erst mal ins Lager.
Bevor ich hier die Gegner bashe.
Zum Lager.
Ja, der Bug ist mega.
Kenn ich.
Auch echt nervig.
Du meinst den Bug wenn...
Ko...
Hast du auch schon mal nen...
Nen Terminal in Visual Studio Code offen gehabt?
Darin...
Nen WIM offen und reingepastet?
Vielleicht liegt das an der Kombination aus...
Windows-Shit.
Visual Studio Code-Shit.
Und...
Ja...
Keine Ahnung.
Noch mehr...
Noch mehr Shit.
Ähm...
Oh, guck mal da hinten.
Was ist da?
Quest-Doors am Start.
Rede mit Halsen über...
Die...
Über was?
Ich weiß gar nicht.
Ich hab...
Ich hab die Quest-Text wahrscheinlich nicht gelesen dafür.
Was soll ich mit Halsen reden?
Ja.
Im letzten Licht erholt sich eine flammende Faust.
Das hört sich auf Deutsch immer so...
So...
So merkwürdig an, oder?
Im letzten Licht erholt sich eine flammende Faust.
Da denkst du auch wenn du das liest, denkst du...
Was wollt ihr von mir?
What?
Der Mann scheint dem Fluch entronnen zu sein.
Hat er...
Ach, das ist die Quest.
Genau.
Also im letzten Licht ist eine Gast...
Ist eine...
So...
Ga...
Gast...
Also...
Wie heißt das?
So eine...
Taverne!
So.
Und äh...
Flaming Fist.
Das ist so eine...
So eine...
So eine Elite...
Soldier-Einheit.
Keine Ahnung.
Alles klar, Halsen.
Jawohl.
Such ihn auf.
Sehr gut.
Ich kann da auch ohne mich.
Ich hab schon...
Ich...
Ich hatte schon die blöde Vermutung.
Ich muss da jetzt mitkommen.
Tag beenden.
Lagervorräte.
Yep.
Yep, Klock.
Also...
Eins muss man Baldur's Gate 3 lassen.
Zählen kann's nicht.
Das wählt immer kompletten Blödsinn aus bei meiner Rast.
Die machen jetzt schon Bettke.
Dabei ist doch noch gar nicht 22 Uhr.
Sind eindeutig zu früh, Bettke.
Fett.
So.
Ich glaub, das war's.
Mehr müssen wir hier nicht...
Warum fehlt denn da ein Spell?
Da fehlt ein Spell.
Oder hatte ich da nie ein Spell?
Ah, ne.
Da hatte ich...
Da hatte ich die...
Die Schriftrolle hingelegt.
Da muss ich mal kurz gucken.
Habe ich noch irgendwas Cooles?
Dass Will was machen kann, wenn er in einem Fight out of...
Oh.
Och, Will.
Dass wenn er...
Out of Spell Slot ist...
Das müssen wir mal kurz checken.
Will hat vielleicht...
Das bringt jetzt nicht sonderlich viel.
Das bringt auch nicht sonderlich viel.
Bringt auch nicht sonderlich viel Gedanken wahrnehmen.
Ja, das könnte man vielleicht machen.
Ähm.
Mage Armor casten.
Okay, passt.
Mal gucken, ob Will noch ein paar...
Wo ist denn meine Truhe?
Ob Will noch ein paar Schriftrollen mitnehmen kann.
Immer separat ist Windows Terminal offen.
Ja, aber das kann doch nicht sein,
dass es Terminal in Visual Studio Code beim Copy-Pasten
in WIM Sonderzeichen einfügt, die gar nicht da sind.
Okay, was heißt, das kann nicht sein?
Das war ja anscheinend offensichtlich so.
Aber das...
Ich...
Ich formuliere jetzt mal...
Das sollte nicht so sein.
So, Will.
Haben wir für dich noch irgendwelche coolen...
Spell Slots?
Ein Beistand.
Will kann heilen.
Na, Will muss nicht heilen.
Burning Hands brauchen wir nicht.
Chromatische Kugel habe ich auch.
So.
Darkness bringt mir nichts.
Feuerschild bringt mir auch nichts.
Cliff bringt mir auch nichts.
Habe ich denn noch ein paar ordentliche...
Ordentliche Schriftrollen?
Okay, Will.
Die kannst du mal einpacken.
Und...
Unsichtbar habe ich als Spell.
Das brauche ich nicht.
Elementare beschwören.
Jawohl, Will.
Das kannst du mitnehmen.
Das ist gut.
Und Mirror Image kannst du auch mitnehmen
für den Fall der Fälle,
wenn du erstmal ein bisschen Defense brauchst.
Exzellent, Will.
Let's go.
Light.
Ja, Killcoin anscheinend.
Ich...
Ich verstehe jetzt nicht, was mit dem los ist.
Warum das...
Windows-technisch so suckt.
Gut.
So, weiter geht's.
Dann schauen wir doch mal.
Dann sch...
Moment.
Jetzt ist die Tür da oben zu?
War die Tür nicht eben noch auf?
Oder gucke ich in die falsche Richtung?
Ah, ich gucke in die falsche Richtung.
So, da müssen wir jetzt hin.
Lass mal kurz...
O...
Observieren, was hier...
Was hier so abgeht drinnen.
Oh, nee.
Die...
Das bringt nichts, wenn ich da hinstelze.
Dann...
Oh, Moment.
Die sind neutral?
Balthasar.
Na dann.
Gucken wir mal.
Was der will.
Bringt mir eine Leber.
Der sieht nicht in One Piece aus.
Ist das so?
Was haben wir denn jetzt zu bieten?
Wer seid...
Wer seid ihr?
Ja.
Ja, das ist...
Würde mich...
Tatsächlich...
Auch mal interessieren.
Eure IT hat letztens Sharepoint von 16 auf 19 hochgezogen.
Jetzt haben wir Probleme.
Ja, Sharepoint an sich ist wahrscheinlich...
Das Problem.
Moment.
Man kann mit dem Dude handeln.
Mal reingucken.
Ah.
Okay.
Ich sehe, der hat nichts...
Womit ich handeln will.
Wir...
Wir sind mal...
Ich würde nicht sagen, dass wir cheaten.
Aber wir...
Gehen mal auf einen anderen Character.
Und gucken mal, ob der...
Was der so kann.
Bevor wir den jetzt attacken.
So, Rüstungsklasse 15.
Das ist gar kein Problem.
Er ist undead.
Was sehr gut ist.
Für mich...
Dann...
Mage-Armor.
Verbündete Untote im Umkreis von bis zu 9.
Sie sind gegen Hieb und Stich und Wuchtschaden resistent.
Ja, gut.
Mach eh wahrscheinlich Feuer-Damage zum größten Teil auf die.
Immun gegen Untote konzentriert.
Einmal pro Zug.
Das ist 300.
Komm, wachsam, Totenschutz.
Okay.
Ich bin...
Mal gucken, was er zu sagen hat.
Ich bin mir noch gar nicht sicher, ob ich angreifen soll.
Wir fragen ihn mal, wer er ist.
Er kann gar keine True Soul selber sein.
Weil ich glaube, Untote können keine Mindflayer werden.
Sag ich so als D&D-Lore-Kenner.
Ich glaube, das geht nicht.
Geschichte.
Der Name Balthasar kommt dir vage bekannt vor.
Kann das sein, dass das ein Charakter aus dem ersten...
Baldur's Gate ist?
Oder aus dem...
Oder aus dem Baldur's Gate 2 Addon?
Ich will jetzt nicht...
Ich will jetzt nicht irgendwie...
Wiki aufmachen und danach suchen.
Okay.
Wir machen...
Wir checken mal, wie schlau Will ist, was Geschichte angeht.
Bonus.
Jawohl, voll ein Bonus.
Alles, gib ihm.
18.
Sehr gut.
Poggers Will.
Das...
Ich...
Ich weiß wo das...
Das ist aus dem Baldur's Gate 2 Addon.
Moment.
Ich muss mal kurz...
Ich muss mal kurz ins Wiki spicken.
Baldur's Gate...
Balthasar...
Baldur's Gate 2?
Ja.
Aus dem Baldur's Gate 2 Addon.
Ha.
Dachte ich mir doch.
Ey, wie findest du das Spiel bisher?
Mega nice.
Es gibt ein paar Punkte, die ich nicht so schön finde.
Zum Beispiel...
Dass die Party auf 4 Charaktere begrenzt ist.
Das find ich nicht so geil.
Also ich hätte...
Ich hätte persönlich auf mindestens 5 gehofft.
Dass man 4 Companions und einen eigenen Charakter reinpacken kann.
Weil so ist die Auswahl einfach ein bisschen...
Bisschen knapp.
Deswegen hab ich auch gar keinen eigenen Charakter erstellt.
Sondern...
Spiel mit einem Origin Charakter.
Ähm...
Ein paar Sachen wären cool.
Hätten sie es...
Hätten sie sich ein bisschen mehr an die Vorlage gehalten.
Gerade, dass es keine Ready Action im Fight gibt.
Ist ein bisschen blöd.
Aber der Rest ist richtig gut.
Ja, das hab ich gelesen.
Dass die...
Den Companion gefixt haben.
Aber den Compa...
Aber Minsara kann man glaub ich eh nur nehmen.
Wenn man...
Evil Playthrough macht.
Okay.
Klärt mich auf.
So wie...
Hier.
Balthasar.
Ich hab mal von einem Mönch mit diesem Namen gehört.
Er ist vor langer Zeit gestorben.
Gut, wir haben ja unseren...
Geschichtswurf erfolgreich bestanden.
Mal gucken was er dazu sagt.
Ne, ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Klärt mich auf.
Ist die Lautstärke okay?
Okay.
Das...
Da kann der lange drauf warten.
Das kann der vergessen, dass ich dem helfe.
Irgendwas...
Zu suchen.
Okay, was können wir dann machen?
Ihr braucht also meine Hilfe.
Was müsste ich tun?
Ist nicht mein Stil mich ohne Information auf einen Auftrag einzulassen.
Was soll ich denn suchen?
Okay, ich bin Warlock und ich hab super krass Hypercharisma und Advantage.
Also Will.
Will.
Wenn du das failst...
Bist du offiziell der schlechteste Warlock ever.
Advantage, Massig, Bonus.
Guck mal, ich krieg 9 bis 12 drauf.
Also ich muss quasi irgendwie eine 3 oder so würfeln, dass es nicht funktioniert.
Okay, und das mit Advantage.
Präge, Will.
Auf geht's.
Doppel...
Doppel 20.
Okay, das ist...
Jetzt hab ich alles gesehen in dem Game.
Jetzt...
Ist vorbei.
Mein Glück ist aufgebraucht.
Glück ist...
Vorbei.
Ab jetzt nur noch Einser.
Macht aber keinen Unterschied, ob ich 14 oder 20 kriege.
Okay.
Aha.
Gut zu wissen.
Der Giga Chat im Hintergrund.
Den werd ich gleich bashen müssen, vermute ich.
Weil ich werd dem garantiert nicht helfen.
Das Relikt verleiht dem General...
Ja, das klingt wie euer Problem, nicht meins.
Böse Holzlade, danke für den Sub.
Das wollen...
Das wollen wir mal sehen.
Einschüchtern.
Man hat immer eine Wahl, ob ich euch leben lasse oder nicht.
Gut, mal sehen, was ich tun kann.
Angreifen.
Nee.
Will ist mega gut im Einschüchtern, weil er hat plus 5 Charisma.
Und plus 3 Proficiency auf...
Einschüchtern-Übung.
Plus Guidance.
Okay, Will.
16.
Will, du machst das schon.
Easy.
Ja, ja, wir sollten's haben.
Ja, ja.
Locker.
Okay, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, was passiert.
Wie, das war's jetzt?
Dach, da kommt noch was.
Okay, also.
Turn-Based-Mode.
Wir werden das jetzt richtig cheesen, den Fight.
Kalak, du rennst schon mal direkt...
...direkt zu dem Typ hin.
Shadow...
Äh, Shadowheart, du gehst hier hin.
Und nachdem die neutral sind, kannst du schon mal Level 4 Spirit Guardians casten.
Ja, kommt nicht ganz dran, egal.
Level 4 Spirit Guardians.
Dann...
...darf Will...
...und Gale...
...ein Stückchen weg.
Der Hund bleibt ein bisschen auf der Seite.
Und mein Imp geht mal hier an das Viech ran.
Okay, ich glaub, wir stehen ziemlich gut.
Und jetzt darf Gale das machen, was er am besten kann.
Fireball casten.
Auf...
...die drei hier.
Das macht übrigens nichts, dass Shadowheart im Weg steht.
Normalerweise würde Shadowheart jetzt gut Damage bekommen.
Aber Gale ist bei mir, äh, ja...
...Invoker-Meister, oder wie auch immer das...
...wie heißt denn das auf Deutsch?
Gale ist bei mir...
...wo steht denn das?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Zumindest sorgt das dafür, dass meine Verbündeten im...
...in, ähm, Flächenzauber-Spells nur minimal Schaden bekommen.
Ich hab...
Zauberformen ist, glaub ich, das Richtigste.
Genau.
Erschaffe sichere Bereiche.
Verbündete Kreaturen haben automatisch Erfolg bei Rettungshürfen gegen Zauber.
Gale sieht mega hässlich aus, aber die Rüstung ist geil.
Ich hätt es, ich hätt es lieber, wenn diese Viecher eigentlich...
...hier stehen würden, anstatt da.
Aber okay, kann man nix machen.
Du kriegst jetzt dick Damage drauf.
Okay.
Gib ihm!
Hey!
Wait, wait a minute!
Bin ich jetzt...
...äh...
Chat!
Bin...
...ich hab mal ne dumme Frage.
Hab ich da jetzt...
...ein...
...hab ich nicht gerade gesehen...
...dass der hier runtergelaufen ist...
...und jetzt ist er wieder hier oben?
Oder hab ich einfach nur Brain Lag?
Ich glaub, ich hab nur Brain Lag, oder?
Ich dachte, ich hab gesehen, dass grad ein Charakter hier...
Habt ihr das auch gesehen?
Ich glaub, das Game...
...hat erst irgendwie...
...berechnet, er müsste da langlaufen...
...und dann ist ihm aufgefallen...
Moment!
Carla kriegt eigentlich ne Opportunity Attack.
Oh, der kriegt...
...der kriegt richtig Damage jetzt.
Bam!
Okay.
Übelkeit auf Kalec.
Ähm...
Gale macht Counterspell.
Will macht nix.
Nochmal!
Alter, wieviel kann der noch?
Okay, nochmal Counterspell.
Zack.
Ich lass dich keinen Zauber rauskriegen.
Ich weiß nicht, was du alles kannst.
Gut.
Nice.
Ähm...
Dann würd ich doch sagen...
...Kalec, du machst den jetzt mal fertig, oder?
Jo.
So, wir haben nur 35 Hit.
Das ist ein bisschen wenig.
Wir sollten...
...vielleicht das ausmachen.
Da kriegen wir 60.
Ja, das ist gut.
Ich...
Ich bin grad am überlegen.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich das benutzen kann.
Plus nen Smite.
Oder ob es...
...Smite, oder...
...das hier ist.
Ich glaube, ich kann nur eins von beiden benutzen.
Bonusaktion.
Ja, das ist ne Bo...
Okay, das ist ne Bonusaktion.
Das ist auch ne Bonusaktion.
Dann kann ich nur eins davon benutzen.
Okay, Damage, please.
Bam.
Ohhhh.
Okay.
Einfach sterben jetzt.
Jawoll.
Easy.
So muss das sein.
Gut, die...
Der Rest...
Der Rest sollte ja wahrscheinlich relativ easy sein.
So, Carla, kannst du noch irgendwas machen, was sinnvoll ist?
Joa, wieder hier runterlaufen zu dem Dude.
Und dem noch nen extra...
...extra Hit geben.
Moment, hier hab ich 90...
...Hitprozent.
Wie viel hab ich damit?
65.
Ach, da probieren wir es damit.
Extra Damage.
Ah, evaded.
Gut.
Nicht schlimm.
Dann...
...kommt...
...Will dran.
Will ist im Warlock.
Da schadet's nix, wenn ich alle beiden Spell Slots raushaue.
Der kriegt die ja wieder.
Wir ma...
Wir...
Wir machen mal auf die Minions Damage.
Hier oben haben wir schon zwei Tanks dran.
Das ist nicht so das Problem.
Du bist an der gleichen Stelle.
Ähm...
Ist halt die Frage, was du sonst noch so hast.
Ich mein...
Ich kann jetzt nix dagegen machen.
Also, da musst du aufpassen.
Ich muss...
Ich kann jetzt nix dagegen machen, falls es dich spoilert.
Wie viel ich sonst schon von dem Akt gemacht hab.
Was du nicht gemacht hast und umgedreht.
Aber ich...
...versuche jetzt erst mal den Dungeon fertig zu machen.
Der Fight war bei dir so eine Katastrophe.
Wieso?
Was...
Wie ist das bei dir gelaufen?
Ich mein...
Der Typ konnte ja bei mir gar nix machen.
Der ist ja quasi Two-Hit gestorben.
So...
Will hat...
...Damage...
Oh...
Will hat gut Damage gemacht.
Will, du gehst mal ein Stückchen weg.
Die können dich im Zweifelfall immer noch gut Damage machen.
Geil.
Geil, weißt du was?
Du killst jetzt einfach mit noch...
Das ist zwar...
Das ist zwar hier die Holzhammer-Methode.
Aber ich mein...
Was soll's?
Machst jetzt einfach nochmal ein Fireball hier drauf.
Dass die sterben.
Ne, wobei...
Vorher...
Erst mal vorher...
Vorher darf der noch Damage machen.
Naja, nix dabei.
Shadowheart kommt später erst dran.
Damn.
Deadge.
Jawohl.
So ist das gut.
Next.
Oh, der Dicke ist ja noch da.
Den hab ich schon ganz vergessen.
Der Typ ist bei dir immer komplett aus der Range gerannt.
Hatte First Turn.
Hat direkt Whole Person.
Andere...
Oh.
Da hatte ich Glück.
Dass ich mich ordentlich platziert habe wahrscheinlich.
Äh...
Kratzer, du darfst Damage hier drauf machen.
Das Game ist manchmal ein bisschen merkwürdig.
Ich mein...
Ziel ist zu weit entfernt.
Ja.
Ob...
Obviously.
Wie man hier sieht.
Ziel ist eindeutig zu weit entfernt.
Okay.
Shadowheart.
Hast du dem schon Damage gemacht oder nicht?
Ja, hast du.
Ja, Shadowheart.
Keine Ahnung.
Hau einfach mal drauf.
Ich mein...
Wir müssen nicht mehr Spell Slots verschwenden.
Wie notwendig.
Zack.
Du bist jetzt nicht der...
Nicht...
Ni...
Ne...
Gift...
Können wir...
Ich...
Ich geh mal da stark von aus, dass die...
Immun gegen Gift sind.
Moment, das ist...
Ist das gar kein Untoter?
Es ist gar kein Untoter.
Also Chat, wenn ich mir den so angucke.
Ich persönlich hätte ja gedacht, das ist nur ein Toter.
Aber...
Nein.
Ist es nicht.
Es ist ein Fleischgolen.
Mal gucken wie viel...
Okay.
Kampf erprobter Zauberwirkerer.
Gelegenheitszauber.
Schockangriff.
Ey, hau einfach noch mal drauf.
Oh, gut.
Okay, vorbei ge...
Also der letzte Fight...
War mega schwer.
Hier, der vor der Tür.
Aber der hier ist easy.
Okay, Will.
Musst nicht mehr Ressourcen verschw...
Musst nicht mehr Ressourcen verschwenden als notwendig.
Darfst den hier schön wegplasten.
Spielst du auch einen Warlock?
Nein.
Ich...
Mein...
Mein Main Character ist Gale.
Der Wizard hier.
Aber ich hab Will dabei.
Weil Will...
Richtig charismatischer Dude ist.
Und ein High Charisma Charakter ist halt sehr praktisch.
Ich hab Karlack Respekt von Barbarian of Paladin.
Allerdings hat er aber ich...
Die hatte nicht so viel Charisma wie ein Pala eigentlich haben sollte in dem Fall.
Aber gut.
Zumindest...
Passt das gut zu ihrer Story, finde ich.
Und Barbarian ist einfach so langweilig.
Das...
Da war ich so richtig hin und her gerissen.
Ich finde das Karlack mit der coolste Companion im ganzen Game ist.
Aber...
Aber Barb ist so langweilig.
Du machst jeden Fight das gleiche.
Rage...
Gegner hitten.
Reckless Attack...
So.
Mehr machst du nicht.
Du hast nicht Gale mitgenommen?
Solltest du unbedingt Gale mitnehmen.
Ohne Wizard kann man...
Also...
Du kannst selbstverständlich spielen wie du willst.
Aber ohne Wizard verpasst du sehr viel.
Also...
Hast du...
Was du brauchst an Tools für den Fight.
Für Fights.
Warlocks haben einfach nicht genug Spell Slots.
Und auch nicht alle Spells.
Alexander Blumen.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Okay Karlack.
Du darfst jetzt das Vieh hier platt machen.
Komm mal her.
Feuerangriff.
Habe ich denn irgendwas gelesen, dass der...
Sekunde.
Habe ich denn irgendwie gerade gesehen, dass der ihm...
Abneigung gegen Feuer.
Ah.
Habe ich doch richtig gesehen.
Dann...
Feuer.
Ja Fighter ist krass.
Aber...
So richtig krass ist...
Ups.
So richtig krass ist Fighter eigentlich erst...
Wenn du die dritte...
Die...
Die dritte...
Den dritten Angriff kriegst.
Und den dritten Angriff...
Kriegst du eigentlich erst ab Level...
Zwölf?
Da ist das Game ja schon vorbei.
Bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
Oder ab...
Oder ab zehn?
Ab wann kriegen Fighter...
Den dritten Angriff?
Elf?
Vielleicht sogar.
Ich weiß es aus dem Kopf nicht.
Ne zwölf kann nicht sein.
Zwölf kriegst du neues Feuer.
Ich weiß nicht.
Wann bekommt...
Das muss ich gerade mal nachgucken.
Fighter...
Wann bekommen Fighter fünf...
Den fünften...
Fünf...
Den dritten Angriff?
Extra Attack.
Extra...
Elf.
Elftes Level.
Ja.
Ab da...
Mag Fighter richtig geil sein.
Gerade mit Haste noch dabei.
Und...
Jetzt überlegt euch mal.
Du hast einen Fighter mit drei Attacks.
Haste.
Und...
Ich weiß nicht wie das auf Deutsch heißt.
Also dieses...
Angriffe resetten.
Da kannst du quasi...
Neun Angriffe machen.
In einer Runde.
Das ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu...
Bisschen...
Bisschen brutal ja.
Aber auch nur mit Haste.
So hier.
Damage.
Bam.
Ach Karla.
Come on.
Da mage.
Jawoll.
Ach man kann das...
Paaren.
Man kann...
Smiten.
Und...
Nieder...
Das ist gut.
Das muss ich mir merken.
Okay das hat nicht viel Damage gemacht.
Aber das gibt...
Das ist ja richtig...
Der...
Also Paladin ist einfach...
Mit eines der krassesten Burst...
Burst Damage Dealer die es so gibt.
So Will.
Du hast deinen Turn schon gehabt.
Gail.
Komm.
Spar Slots.
Ja.
Den kriegen wir auch so easy down.
Kratzer.
Komm mal.
Ein...
Ein TP noch.
Und jetzt kriegt er den Kritz.
Shadowheart.
Komm her.
Hau drauf.
Wow.
Alter was ist mit dir los?
Was ist mit meinem...
Was war das?
Irgendeine Reaction?
Okay.
Will kann ihn finishen.
Karla.
Erstmal drauf hauen.
Nein.
Wir smiten nicht.
Wir hauen nochmal drauf.
Nicht smiten.
Wir...
Save...
Wir save ein bisschen.
Bisschen Spar Slots.
Okay.
Will.
Vielleicht haben wir Glück.
Warum hast du die Leiste auf nur zwei Reihen?
Weiß ich nicht.
Weiß ich das noch nicht.
Ich weiß...
Wie macht man das?
Ich weiß dass das geht.
Aber ich weiß gar nicht wo.
Ach hier mehr Reihen.
Jo.
Ich hab hier alles drauf was ich brauch.
Ich hab das...
Guck ich hab sogar noch ein und ein.
Warlock hat ja nicht viel.
Für...
Ganz ehrlich.
Für Shadowheart könnte ich es gebrauchen.
Aber ich klick eigentlich dann immer hier unten.
Also bis jetzt.
Bis jetzt.
Okay.
Gail.
Ne.
Shadowheart ist dran.
Dead.
Easy win.
Shadowheart ist inspired.
Das ist schön...
Schön für Shadowheart.
Aber ich glaub die hatte schon 4 Inspire Punkte.
Hat einer von euch auch das merkwürdige Phänomen?
Dass die...
Die...
Die Partymembers...
Unterschiedliche Zeiten Level Up haben.
Am Anfang war das alles synchron.
Aber seit...
Weiß ich nicht.
Seit Level 5 oder so.
Haben teilweise die Level Up...
Irgendwie 200 XP vorher und sowas.
Ganz...
Ganz weird.
Ach jetzt ist synchron.
Ich hatte es auch nur ein Level Up.
Aber das war das letzte.
Letzte 2 vielleicht.
Weiß nicht.
Okay.
Erstmal Augen aufheben.
Yep.
Clock.
Gemüsekiste.
Wie beim Edeka.
Ja.
Heiltrank.
Sehr gut.
Kann man immer gebrauchen.
Wo ist denn der Boss?
Den muss ich auch noch looten.
Ah da oben.
Oh hier wird gelootet.
Was ist hier?
Eingeweide.
Eingeweide looten.
Was sonst?
Schwere Truhe.
Ach die Inspiration gibt nur für 1 XP.
Aha.
Mondlaterne hab ich alles schon.
Brauch ich nicht mehr.
Ich sammle das trotzdem mal ein.
Fleisch.
Fleisch wird gelootet.
Oh ja.
Hmm.
Das...
muss man unbedingt looten.
Balthasar.
Was hast du denn dabei?
Ein Buch.
Seelenkäfig Forschung.
Wir lesen das nicht.
Ich klicke das immer nur an.
Falls es Quests gibt.
Oder Quests.
Progress.
Methoden.
Ich vermute mal.
Das Game möchte von mir,
dass ich mit dem rede.
Urländisch hören.
Clock.
Ah.
Moment.
Kann ich?
Wartet mal.
Ich muss mal safen.
Das muss ich ausprobieren.
Doch.
Ich hab ihn angesprochen.
Aber ich...
Vielleicht sagt er noch mehr.
Oh mein Gott.
Das muss ich ausprobieren.
Wartet mal.
Kann ich damit dieses fette Ding beschwören?
Corpse wants to speak but not to the killer.
Moment.
Das ist echt ein Ding.
Aber Will hat ihn nicht gekillt.
Kar...
Kalec hat ihn gekillt.
Ähm.
Zauberwirken.
Ach so.
Ziel darf kein Untoter sein.
Okay.
Das ergibt natürlich Sinn.
Schon wieder Ballerskate 5.
Ja.
Wochenende wird gebastelt wieder.
Aber ich wollte...
Ich hatte mega Bock weiter zu spielen.
Und du...
Du hast mich motivated.
Weil du tatsächlich...
Und du warst ja nicht...
Sogar nicht der einzige.
Ähm.
Gefragt hast.
Ob ich...
Wann...
Wann ich wieder Stream mache.
Und da dachte ich mir.
Ich kann das Ganze auch im Stream machen.
Why not?
Haben wir alles?
Alles?
Gelootet?
Ja.
Alles...
Ohne...
Ah.
Kommt man nicht hin.
Okay.
Hala.
Kommst du da oben hin?
Brauchen wir eh nicht.
Gut.
Also.
Was haben wir gelernt?
Wir haben gelernt.
Dass hier irgendein Artefakt versteckt ist.
Was...
Den...
Boss von Act 2.
Vermutlich.
Schaden nehmen lässt.
Und dann ist er nicht mehr immun.
Also das heißt.
Im Endeffekt.
Ich muss das machen.
Anders geht nicht.
Achso.
Habe ich mir das Loot richtig angeguckt?
Was hat der denn hier?
Klochenkreis.
Verbündete Untote im Umkreis von bis zu 6 Meter sind gegen...
Kiep, Stich und Wuchtschaden.
Okay.
Wir bekommen einmal gratis...
Tote wiederbeleben.
Das dumme ist.
Also.
Eigentlich ist das ganz cool.
Aber.
Die Summons...
Sacken halt ziemlich.
Also insofern.
Wahrscheinlich werde ich das nicht benutzen.
Was hat Kale?
Okay.
Die kann heilen ein bisschen.
Das ist übrigens.
Eigentlich.
Also.
Auf einem Paladin ziemlich unsinnig.
Aber den AE Heal finde ich gut.
Ne.
Es geht nicht wieder.
Kann man nicht wiederbeleben.
Das ist gut.
Weil.
In.
5E.
Ist.
Egal.
Mit wie wenig du jemand heilst.
Der steht immer wieder auf.
Deswegen ist es Heal.
Einfach das opeste was es gibt.
Ja.
Das kann Shadow Heart nie ablegen.
Das komplette Playthrough nicht.
Die braucht.
Äh.
Misty Step.
Gail.
Was hast du denn?
Einen freien.
Dritten Slot Spell.
Ist auch ziemlich gut.
Und Will.
Hat.
Schild.
Das würde ich Will auch lassen.
Weil Will hat sonst nicht so viel.
Defense.
Joa.
Moment.
Das ist gar keine Halskette.
Oder?
Das ist ein.
Das ist ein Helm.
Gail.
Du hast doch noch keinen Helm auf.
Anderen haben alle einen Helm.
Gail.
Du hast noch keinen Helm.
Das ist.
Das Beste für dich.
Du kriegst einen Helm.
An.
Gail.
Senden.
Excellent Choice.
Gail.
Jetzt siehst du.
Wie ein ordentlicher Zauberer aus.
Leider sieht die Rüstung mies aus.
Aber gut.
Kann man nichts machen.
Dafür ist die Rüstung op.
Sehr schön.
Gut.
Dann würde ich sagen.
Einmal.
Short Rest.
Dass Will wieder seine.
Zauber Slots bekommt.
Gail.
Darf sich.
Einmal.
Nen.
Third Level.
Spell.
Zurückholen.
Und.
Einmal.
Nen.
First Level.
Spell.
Und.
Nochmal.
Nen.
Third Level.
Spell Slots.
Shadow Heart.
Hat kaum was raus.
Und.
Kale.
Kann auch genug.
Weiter gehts.
Vergoldete Truhe.
Oh.
Was.
Was haben wir denn da.
Ach.
Gift.
Da brauche ich nicht.
Ich habe keinen Stelzer.
Der mit Gift.
Hantiert.
War hier noch irgendwas.
Sieht.
Sieht leer aus.
Hammer.
Alles.
Gelotet.
Okay.
Hm.
Wir kommen.
Von.
Hier.
Unten.
Also.
Ich weiß.
Dass es.
Geradeaus geht.
Und rechts.
Das heißt.
Ich würde sagen.
Wir gehen jetzt.
Nach.
Norden.
Da scheint.
Nämlich.
Der letzte.
Raum.
Auf der Map.
Zu sein.
Weil es.
Ansonsten.
Nicht weiter geht.
Ha.
Denke ich mal.
Weil hier.
In die Mitte.
Weiß ich ja.
Dass weiter geht.
Aber ich meine.
Ich kenne die Maps.
Ja auch nicht.
Also.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich hoffe.
Ich habe alles gelotet.
Ich habe nichts.
Übersehen.
Pets.
Sind auch noch.
Alle da.
Die flinken Finger.
Von.
Gail.
Sind wieder.
Gefragt.
Weiß.
Dass.
Verschlossen ist.
30.
Wow.
Also.
Ich meine.
Ne.
Wir haben.
Keine Chance.
Okay.
Doch.
Wir hätten.
Theoretisch.
Eine Chance.
Und zwar.
Wenn wir eine.
20 Würfel.
Oder.
Wenn ich.
Eine.
18 Würfel.
Und.
Ich.
Plus.
4.
8.
Ne.
Ich wusste.
20 Würfel.
Keine Chance.
Trotzdem.
Theoretisch.
Das bringt nichts.
Ey.
Ja.
Aber.
Ich habe.
Geld dabei.
Und jetzt nochmal.
Für alle.
Zweifler.
Im Chat.
Jetzt.
Zeige ich euch.
Warum.
Ein Wizard.
Dabei.
Zu haben.
Einfach das.
Beste.
Ist.
Was.
Ihr haben.
Könnt.
Weil.
Gail.
Hat.
Nämlich.
Wenn er.
Selbst nicht.
In der Lage ist.
Ein Schloss.
Aufzumachen.
Nehmen wir.
Einfach.
Knock.
Nehmen wir.
Einfach.
Knock.
Und.
Machen.
Die Tür.
Mit nem.
Spell.
Auf.
Glaub ich.
Level 2.
Spell.
Knocker.
Klopfen.
Nennt sich.
Das.
Deutsch.
Klopfen.
Wie bloß.
Da.
Dankeschön.
Für den.
Sub.
Knock.
Und schon ist das.
Tor auf.
Easy.
Deswegen.
Braucht ihr.
Wizards.
Weil nur.
Alle.
Spells.
Haben.
Oder.
Sorcerer.
Gehen.
Auch noch.
Aber.
Deswegen.
Ist es.
Blöd.
Ganz ohne Wizard.
Zu.
Spielen.
Die haben.
Super.
CC.
Spells.
Damage.
Utility.
Spells.
Also.
Eigentlich.
Ist es.
Blöd.
Wenn man.
Ohne Wizard.
Die sind.
Bestimmt.
Also.
Leute.
Wenn.
Wenn die.
Keine.
Wenn.
Wenn das.
Keine.
Trap.
Traps.
Sind.
Okay.
Keine.
Traps.
Was.
Feuer.
An.
Hallo.
Skelett.
Rucksack.
Erstmal.
Hier.
Alles.
Luten.
Lute.
Reno.
Jawohl.
Die Sandalen.
Die habe ich.
Gebraucht.
Ohne.
Sandalen.
Hätte ich.
Ruhe.
Gas.
Förmige.
Gestalt.
Bindung.
Der.
Ebenen.
Und.
Schnee.
Schneesturm.
Das.
Ist.
Gut.
Das.
Darf.
Will.
Behalten.
Das.
Ist.
Ein.
Spell.
Den.
Kann.
Man.
Immer.
Mal.
Gebrauchen.
Wenn.
Will.
Out of.
Spell.
Slots.
Ist.
Lass.
Mal.
Kurz.
Gucken.
Ob.
Gail.
Noch.
Was.
Lernen.
Kann.
An.
Neuen.
Zaubern.
Erst.
Ah.
Infernalisches.
Eisen.
Da können wir.
Kalack.
Upgraden.
Org.
Ring.
Der.
Kaltherzigen.
Leuchtträger.
Bewirkt.
Zusätzlich.
Zwei.
Schadenspunkte.
Gegen.
Kreaturen.
Die.
Erhält.
Sind.
Wait a minute.
Meinen.
Die.
Damit.
Gegen.
Gegner.
Die.
Nicht.
In.
Schatten.
Also.
Die.
Im.
Licht.
Stehen.
Oder.
Die.
Markiert.
Sind.
Mit.
Zum.
Beispiel.
Das.
Man.
Weiß.
Es.
Nicht.
So.
Genau.
Aber.
Mit.
Alles.
Genommen.
Und.
Wir.
Haben.
Richtig.
Erkannt.
Dass.
Die.
Map.
Hier.
Zu.
Ende.
Ist.
Guck.
Mal.
Was.
Ist.
Da.
Oben.
Wie.
Groß.
Ist.
Das.
Eigentlich.
Die.
Map.
Huge.
Hier.
Nach.
Rechts.
Geht.
Es.
Auch.
Noch.
Ja.
Gut.
Dann.
Können.
Wir.
Da.
Kann.
Ich.
Eigentlich.
Noch.
Hier.
Lang.
Der.
Tempel.
Ist.
Huge.
Ja.
Ich.
Sehe.
Es.
Gerade.
Was.
Immer.
Liegend.
Oh.
Leute.
Ich.
Rieche.
Wieder.
Fallen.
Ja.
Eng.
In.
Der.
Leichnam.
Ist.
Hier.
Was.
Probier.
Mal.
Was.
Okay.
Das.
Geht.
Nicht.
Ich.
Kann.
Nicht.
Mit.
Dem.
Auf.
Ge.
Mit.
Dem.
Auf.
Ichー.
Kann.
Nur.
Nicht.
Weg.
Oh.
Mach.
Wie.
Zu.
Guarantäte.
Damit es.
Es.
Passiert.
Welt.
Luz.
Bildung.
Welt.
Gelegenheit.
Land.
Weg.
War.
Liegen.
Befühl.
Den.
Lehrern.
Verminnern.
Nochmal,
Wir leben.
Lege uns alt.
Zu.
Leveln.
Hell
Ehemah.
Der.
пал.
Gglass.
Abu.
It.
Klar.
Und.
Ich.
Seh.
Kauf.
Für.
Ich er.
Ich.
Hier ist ein Teleporter!
Oh gut, nice!
Aber es ist eine Ratte, mit der müssen wir reden.
Greifen nicht die Ratte an!
Sollen die mal...
Sollen die mal hier weiter rumstilzen.
Alter, das ist riesig hier, ey!
Ich gehe mal davon aus, da unten ist einfach...
...out of map.
Wo geht es hier lang?
Hier müssen wir...
Ach, da ist noch eine Ratte! Moment, hier ist noch eine Ratte.
Wobei, ich will eigentlich noch nicht hier runter gehen.
Aber wir reden trotzdem mal mit der.
Sind hier so viele Ratten?
Ach, vielleicht habe ich auch aus Versehen eine Ratte gekillt.
Kann schon sein.
Ich möchte das lesen, please.
Darf man nicht.
Okay, gibt es nicht.
Gehen wir mal hier rum.
Ich hoffe ja, dass man...
...dass man hier runter kommt...
...und dann auf die rechte Seite mal gucken kann.
Weil hier oben geht es ja eindeutig weiter.
Oh, was ist denn hier?
Boah, das ist ja riesig groß hier, man!
Da wird heute noch...
...da wird heute noch ein bisschen Dungeon gecrawled.
Angst, dass hier überall noch Fallen sind.
Ein Bogen?
Ja, das ist ja schön und gut.
Aber ich habe niemanden der Bogen verwendet.
Ist das denn wenigstens ein Kurzbogen,
dass ihn theoretisch jeder verwenden kann?
Ja.
Das wäre was für Astarion,
wenn ich mit Astarion spielen würde.
Astarion ist der einzige Companion,
den ich nicht mag.
Also, ich mag keine Vampir-Stories.
Und irgendwie...
...habe ich auch keinen Bock auf einen Rogue in der Party.
Boah, Alter, Alter.
Arcane Schloss.
Okay, das werde ich.
Kann ich das von hier innen aufmachen?
Ach!
Gucke mal an!
Ich meine, da komme ich wieder in den Raum da vorne, ja?
Oh, das ist der nervige Raum.
Leasel habe ich quasi die Hälfte
oder drei Viertel meines Playthroughs
bisher gespielt, ja?
Weil ich einen ordentlichen
Melee-Damage-Dealer
in der Hand habe.
Melee-Damage-Dealer-Tank gebraucht habe.
Der nicht
Barbarian ist, weil Barbarian ist
einfach nur stinkelangweilig.
Deswegen habe ich
Kalak umgespeckt, einfach auf Paladin.
Ich könnte
jetzt aber gar nicht sagen,
was
unterm Strich letztendlich besser ist in dem Game.
Paladin hat natürlich
deutlich besseren Support
und auch erstmal den besseren Burst-Damage.
Aber Leasel
hittet besser
und ist mobiler. Also insofern
ja, ich frage mich ja
immer noch, was mit diesen
Lampen los ist.
Das habe ich schon gelootet, gell?
So, gehen wir mal hier rein, gucken.
Auf der Seite war ich nämlich noch nicht.
Hier ist nichts. Doch, ein Abgrund-
Griecher.
Ich habe übrigens noch nicht
eine Sache. Chat, falls einer von euch
gerade noch am Spielen ist,
seid ihr auch jemand,
der so eine Ableitung gegen In-Game
Alchemie-Crafting-Systeme
hat? Ich habe mein
ganzes Playthrough, ich weiß gar nicht, wo das genau ist.
Ich glaube hier irgendwo. Ich habe mein
ganzes Playthrough nicht
einen Trank, nicht eine Sache hiervon
bisher gecraftet.
Das ist geil, was man da so craften kann hier.
Mächtiger Heiltrank kann ich
craften.
Weißt du, ich habe echt
noch nie benutzt.
Ich will das auch gar nicht. Ich habe gar keinen Bock drauf.
Das Game ist erstens eh nicht, sondern
nicht schwer und zweitens hat man eh genug
an Ressourcen.
Hier ist ja gar nichts.
Ich dachte, hier wäre noch was.
Ich nehme alles mit.
Jede Vase wird hier gelootet.
Wir können ein bisschen abkürzen.
Wir sind hier
langgelaufen, also können wir eigentlich wieder hochporten.
Du hast auch nicht Lust zu
alchemieren, ja verständlich.
Gut.
Hier ging es auch lang.
Ich würde sagen, wir gehen erst mal
auf der rechten Seite lang.
Wir tasten uns hier mal
ein bisschen lang.
Moment, hier geht es noch weiter.
Alter, ist das groß.
Was ist das da unten?
Ah,
guck mal, eine Täuschungsbasis.
Ich weiß gar nicht, haben die Dinge
offizielle deutsche Übersetzung? Ja, müssen sie.
Das müsste eigentlich ein Defiler Beast sein.
Im Original.
Jetzt geht es los.
He doesn't know, he lacks critical information.
Soll ich doch noch mal
long resten vorher vielleicht?
Das ist halt nur eine.
Das ist schon mal verdächtig.
Okay, ich will
hier in keine Trap laufen.
Deswegen...
Du kommst da nicht hin.
Willst du mich rollen?
Du kannst fliegen, natürlich kommst du da hin.
Ich hoffe, die haben kein TrueSight
oder irgendwas, dass sie Unsichtbares sehen kann.
Äh, hier ist nix.
Das ist ein Defiler Beast.
Moment, hier drüben geht es weiter.
Okay, das ist bis jetzt
ein Defiler Beast.
Level 5, das kann mir eigentlich
nicht allzu viel machen.
Aber ich fürchte, das ist nicht alles.
Schau, das steht da auch einfach
zu offensichtlich rum.
Okay, du gehst mal da hin, Imp.
Alles klar.
Okay, dann würde ich sagen, wir machen
jetzt einfach mal... Ach, na okay,
Imp, dann kommen wir da hochgeflogen.
Wir machen jetzt einfach mal Single-Target-Damage
und gucken...
gucken, was passiert.
Will, du gehst... Äh, Gale,
du gehst mal ein bisschen vor.
Pet, du gehst auch vor.
Kala, du gehst ganz vorne hin,
weil du bist der Tank.
Ah.
Und du kannst eigentlich
da unten hingehen.
Shadowheart, du bleibst hier.
Gut. Okay, Will, geb ihm.
Ich mein, wenn ich Glück habe...
Leute, Leute, passt mal auf.
Passt mal auf.
Wenn ich Glück habe,
fliegt das Viech jetzt
die Klippe runter.
Passt mal auf.
Wow.
Es ist auch nicht die...
nicht die Klippe runtergeflogen.
Oh.
Hätte man die...
Okay, Chat, Chat.
Ich bin hier vorhin langgeflogen
mit meinem...
Das ist... Das Game hat mich
gebatet. Ich bin hier zum Scouten
langgeflogen vorhin mit meinem Imp.
Da waren die Dinger noch gar nicht da.
Mit denen kannst du reden.
Hätte ich vielleicht
machen sollen.
Aber die habe ich nicht gesehen eben.
Mit meinem Imp.
Wie? Ich kann mit denen reden.
Das Viech greift mich doch instant an.
Wenn ich da vorbeilaufe.
Nun gut.
Jetzt zu spät.
Passt mal auf. Das ist die Firebeast.
Jetzt fliegt sie.
Jetzt fliegt sie in den Abgrund.
Passt mal auf. Easy.
Doch nicht.
Wie jetzt?
Runter?
Lul.
Not like this.
Mehr Twitchy-Mods.
Ihr seid immer noch überrascht.
Das ist schön für euch, dass ihr überrascht seid.
Seid mal weiterhin überrascht.
Oh, der ist unsichtbar.
Oh, das ist schlecht.
Das ist schlecht,
wenn du irgendwelche Unsichtbaren rumstellst.
Ich habe zwar unsichtbare Sehen,
aber ich habe das nicht
im Spellbook drin.
Das Game hat mich einfach
wieder gebatet.
Das Game hat mich wieder gebatet.
Meine anderen Charakter sind einfach noch
gar nicht im Fight drin.
Es ist nur Will und der Hund.
Sonst nichts.
Geil. Nice.
Gebatet hat es mich.
Der Hund stirbt jetzt, glaube ich.
So, dann, wenn die noch nicht
im Fight drin sind,
dann würde ich vorschlagen,
lohnt es sich,
hier runter zu gehen?
Ehrlich gesagt, lohnt sich das nicht.
Weil,
die Viecher sollen hier einfach angerannt
kommen und ich Fireball
die Dead.
So, Karle kann auch Range-Damage machen.
Das ist auch okay.
Vollkommen in Ordnung.
Heelschlagen.
Hä?
What? Ach, die ist jetzt gar nicht dran.
Na gut.
Shadowheart kann auch Range-Damage machen.
Okay.
Shadowheart.
Wie viele hatten das noch? 18.
Es ist dead.
Drei.
Okay, Will.
Äh, nicht Will.
Gail, du machst es jetzt.
90%. Please nicht verkacken, Gail.
Es ist dead.
Ich würde fast sagen,
wir warten jetzt, bis die Viecher
rankommen.
Ja, Kratzer, du kommst ein Stück zurück.
Ja, kommt ihr mal ran.
Ich will, dass ihr schön,
dass ihr euch schön zusammen klumpt.
Dass ich euch bashen kann.
Ja, ja, kommt ihr mal her.
Ich glaube,
der ist gebuggt.
Was geht mit
Yu-Gi-Oh ab?
Yu-Gi-Oh.
Ein Stufe 10 Unhold.
Ein Unhold.
Die sollen...
Ehrlich gesagt,
ich will meinen Turn jetzt gar nicht nehmen.
Die sollen
zu mir kommen.
Ich will nicht, dass ich zu denen gehen muss.
Ich scheiß drauf.
Ich warte jetzt einfach,
bis die rankommen.
Shadowheart könnte schon mal
Spiritual Weapon casten oder so.
Ja, ist gut.
Komm her.
Gut, jetzt kann ich was machen.
Jetzt ist zumindest schon mal einer da.
Und Kratzer, mach ihm...
Ziel ist...
Das Ziel ist nicht zu weit entfernt, Gail.
Hallo?
Okay, Carla.
Gib ihm.
Dann würde ich sagen,
machen wir mal Damage.
Irgendwas...
Resistenzen, Feuer, Kälte,
Gift.
Okay, aber gegen Radiant Damage
ist fast nichts immun.
Das ist immer äußerst Pog.
Okay, der ist sehr schwer zu treffen.
Das lassen wir mal.
So ist besser.
Haben wir sonst noch irgendwas?
Betäubt...
Betäuben wäre auf denen enorm praktisch,
aber es hat nicht funktioniert.
Hat aber nicht funktioniert.
Mehr gibt es hier nicht.
Okay, Gail,
du darfst Damage machen.
Und zwar...
Was war der?
Feuer, Kälte? Der war ja ziemlich gegen alles.
Gift, Kälte,
Feuerresistenz.
Nekrotisch?
Das kann ja wenigstens nicht geheilt werden.
Okay.
Leute, wir machen mal ein bisschen...
Ja, das war doof von mir.
Ich hätte Karnak Haste geben sollen
mit Gail.
Dann hätte die den vielleicht nicht
finishen können, aber...
Okay, wir beschwören einfach mal was.
Das ist okay, Gail, du darfst mal hinten weg.
Dass der dir kein Damage macht.
Will?
Du machst das einzige, was du gut kannst.
Eldricks Blast auf den.
Ich gehe nicht davon aus, dass der zurückgeworfen werden kann,
weil der bestimmt heavy ist.
Doch, kann er.
Sehr gut.
Du gehst auch mal ein Stück zurück.
Du hast ohne Wizard gespielt.
Daran muss es liegen, Wellendogs.
So.
Ich bin mir jetzt nicht sicher,
ob ich mit Shadowheart
da reinjumpen soll.
Ah.
Ja, komm, scheiß drauf.
Ich mein, guck mal, was ist hier noch,
wovor man Schiss haben muss?
Ein paar Level 5er.
Wen juckt's?
Level 5er sind Futter.
Komm, wir machen das mal mit dem dritten...
Third Level Spell Slot.
Pot of Reroller Class.
Ich will halt nichts vergimpftes spielen.
Dafür spiele ich es auch auf schwer.
Ich mein, das sollte ja irgendwann...
Wenn es nicht notwendig ist,
ein bisschen optimierte Party und so zu haben,
dann fragt man sich, wann dann, ja?
Cluster? Moment, die haben Granaten?
Okay.
Das ist schlecht,
wenn die Granaten haben,
weil ich bin jetzt hier extra runtergesprungen.
Oh, wow!
Okay.
Nun gut.
Moment, wo ist das Vieh hin?
Das ist unsichtbar jetzt, oder was?
Wait a minute!
Der ist...
Ja, ich hab kein See in Invisible und sowas.
Wo ist er?
Okay, Shadowheart, du kannst Kala wiederbeleben.
Ist Shadowheart gestunt?
Ah, nee, Shadowheart ist gar nicht dran.
Hat Gale...
Wie heißt das? Wiederbeleben?
Nee, Gale hat gar keine Wiederbeleben-Schriftrollen.
Will, hast du welche?
Nee, wie heißt der Kram nochmal?
Doch, Wiederbeleben.
Oh, das ist natürlich blöd,
dass ich ihn nur auf meinem Cleric hab.
Ich glaub, jetzt hab ich ein bisschen reingeschissen.
Ich muss mal schauen,
dass Shadowheart irgendwie überlebt.
Okay, der Typ ist unsichtbar.
Wir könnten ein Fireball draufhauen.
Dann kriegt Shadowheart vielleicht ein bisschen...
Aber...
Ich weiß nicht, wo das...
Ich hab nicht hingeguckt.
Ich weiß nicht, wo der hingerannt ist.
Man kann die im Kampf
nicht hin- und herschieben, wie man lustig ist.
Was meinst du?
Also, ich kann hier dazwischen auswählen,
was ich machen will,
aber ich kann jetzt nicht
Shadowheart anklicken.
Anklicken schon, aber nicht machen,
weil Shadowheart ist nicht dran.
Okay, ich hab eine Idee, was wir jetzt machen.
Wir gucken jetzt, wo der Gegner ist.
Ich mein, da kann er nicht so weit sein.
Hier war er nicht.
Ich hoffe, der wird aufgedeckt,
wenn man Damage macht.
Das ist nicht zwangsläufig so.
Nur wenn er sein Concentration
Save
fehlt, je nachdem, was das für eine Unsichtbarkeit ist.
Okay, nee, hier war er nirgendwo.
Schon mal ziemlich doof.
Äh, nee.
Du kannst nicht während den Runden...
Oder? Ich glaube nicht.
Es würde mich wundern, wenn das geht.
Wie, doch, es geht?
Das ist mir neu.
Das wusste ich nicht, dass das funktioniert.
Kann das sein?
Welche Range haben diese Rollen?
Sind die nicht auf Touch?
Ach nee, hier sind sie.
Aber so nah kommt Gale nicht dran.
Ich mein, Gale könnte jetzt...
Gale könnte jetzt den absoluten
YOLO-Move machen und da reinporten
und nee, nee, nee.
Das macht Gale nicht.
Gale bleibt schön hier oben stehen
und macht gar nichts die Runde.
Außer...
Okay, Gale.
MVP-Play.
Äh, wo ist mein Spell hin?
Habe ich den gerade gelöscht?
Zauberbuch.
Crater Invisibility.
Du machst jetzt Shadowheart?
Du machst jetzt Shadowheart unsichtbar?
In der Hoffnung, ich komme da dran.
Ist es auf Touch?
Shit.
Das ist doof.
Keine Ahnung.
Okay, ich...
Ich sehe keine Gegner.
Weiß nicht, wo der hin ist.
Will, du machst dich mal unsichtbar.
Das schadet auf jeden Fall nichts.
Und Gale, du kannst...
Hast du irgendwelche Schriftrollen dabei?
Ah, Dimension Door.
Das wäre jetzt praktisch gewesen.
Okay, scheiß drauf.
Du wirfst jetzt einfach
den Heildrang auf Shadowheart.
Wurscht.
Ich weiß nicht, was er sonst machen soll.
Zugbänden.
Ja.
Ich habe geguckt.
Die Unsichtbarkeit von dem Gegner hält bloß 2 Runden.
Das ist die kleine Invisibility.
Erstmal Shadowheart in Ruhe.
Okay, Carla.
Du bist wieder am Start.
Was?
Jetzt müsste ich nur noch gucken,
dass Carla nicht wieder stirbt.
Direkt.
Das wird sie auf jeden Fall nicht retten.
Deswegen wollte ich eigentlich
drauf casten.
Ich meine, besser als gar nichts ist es.
Aber ganz ehrlich, ist es besser,
die geht nochmal down, anstatt
meinen Slot zu verschwenden.
Dafür machen wir lieber
auch ein Schwert, dass wir ein bisschen
Damage machen können.
Okay, und wir laufen dahin,
falls dieser Boss
wieder auf die Idee kommt,
AE-Hit zu machen und Carla
runterzuschmeißen.
Oh, oh. Oh, shit.
Ich glaube, wir kriegen gerade
so ein kleines Problem.
Okay, die sind noch weit genug weg.
Okay, ich glaube, wir haben jetzt echt
ein kleines Problem.
Das ist okay.
Vollkommen in Ordnung.
Das ist vollkommen
in Ordnung.
Weil Carla ist nicht richtig down,
sondern
kann jetzt geheilt werden.
Moment, der Typ ist
wieder unsichtbar.
Das sackt ja mal heftig.
Mir ist echt
unschlüssig, was ich machen soll.
Ich meine, Carla ist
eh down. Wenn ich da jetzt nochmal extra
Damage drauf mache, sterben wird sie
davon nicht.
Komplett.
Und die sollte, ist halt
die Frage, ob sie heilbar dann noch ist.
Shadowheart muss das
irgendwie überleben.
Okay, wir machen das anders.
Wir C10.
Kann ich...
Ich will nicht...
Ich will Shadowheart nicht
und kann nicht C10.
Gibt es da nicht irgendwie eine Möglichkeit,
hier das... Game.
Hier, das Game hat keinen Bock.
Ich glaube, ich lecke
Critical Information, wie man richtig
target...
Game! Alter!
Okay, scheiß drauf.
Also wenn Shadowheart hypnotisiert wird, bin ich verloren.
Okay.
Zwei Stück.
Der nicht, Shadowheart auch nicht, Carla
auch nicht. Sehr schön.
Und der Boss? Der Boss auch nicht.
Ja, vielleicht bin ich
lost. Mal gucken.
Ja.
Wir sollten mal ein Damage machen auf den hier.
Soll ich was machen?
Sind die feuerimmun
oder irgendwas? Können wir da ordentlich...
Alter, feuerresistent
auch noch.
Okay, Will, du machst jetzt was anderes.
Heil...
Trank.
Trank der überlegenen Heilung. Perfekt.
Werfen. Nice.
Welcome back.
Okay, Carla
kann nicht wirklich großartig was machen.
Aber sie kann auf jeden Fall
schon mal die Aura wieder einschalten.
Und zu dem Gegner hingehen.
Und den versuchen zu stunnen.
Ja.
Ah, bisschen extra Damage.
Shadowheart sollte besser nicht down gehen.
Das wäre sehr unvorteilhaft.
Wer bewegt sich?
Der da.
Vorbei. Sehr gut.
Okay, über...
Vergif...
So, okay.
Jetzt sind wir zum ersten Mal
ordentlich am Start mit Shadowheart.
Was...
Was machen wir da jetzt?
Ich würde sagen, wir casten Spirit Guardians, weil Spirit Guardians
OP ist.
So.
Und dann müssen wir aber...
Ich meine, wir können einen Spellslot zum Heilen
raushauen, okay.
Da müssen wir aber so moven,
dass nur der, der nicht hypnotisiert
ist... Ah, hallo.
Hallo.
Und jetzt kann er auch nicht mehr...
Jetzt kann er auch nicht mehr sich tarnen,
weil er ja
in den Spirit Guardians ist.
Ne, ne, ne.
Du bleibst in Spirit Guardians drin.
Moment, kann man mehrfach Damage machen
auf die?
Ne. Wollte gerade sagen,
das wäre ziemlich OP.
So, der Boss ist fast...
Ohne Scheiß, Leute, wenn wir den Boss tot kriegen,
dann haben wir das gewonnen.
Ne, ich glaube nicht,
dass man mehrfach Damage machen kann.
Guck.
Ne.
Geht nicht.
Doch!
Also wenn das geht, wenn das gehen sollte,
ist das OP as fuck.
Das sind auch keine
Untoten oder sowas hier.
Oh, das werden mir langsam ein bisschen viele.
Ja, ja, geht auf Kala.
Perfekt.
Sehr gut, sehr gut. Und haut vorbei vor allem.
Ja, und schießt
auf das Ding. Sehr gut, sehr gut.
Ja, schieß, schieß.
Spirituelle Waffe ist dran.
80%, Vorteil, 24.
Okay, die kann nicht genug Damage machen, aber wir können vielleicht...
D8 plus 4.
Wir können vielleicht Bleeding verursachen
und dann stirbt er automatisch.
Oh!
Wow, wow!
Was ist das gewesen?
Ihr seht Minen?
Oh, das ist schlecht.
Oh, oh!
Oh, shit!
Okay, wait a minute.
Jetzt haben wir ein Problem.
Wart mal.
Wie?
Untersuchen?
Eine starke Explosion bei deinem Gegner.
Ein verbleibender Zug.
Okay, ich glaube,
ich kann rauslaufen noch.
Wir müssen auf jeden Fall den Boss killen.
Guck mal, der hat noch 8.
Der hat noch 8 Punkte.
Der kriegt jetzt einmal
Magic Missile drauf.
Oder kann ich vielleicht sogar?
Wobei, da weiß ich nicht, ob das reicht.
Der kriegt einmal Magic Missile drauf und dann ist er down.
Und was mache ich mit meinem
verbleibenden Zug?
Gail, was machst du
mit deinem verbleibenden Zug?
Ne, ne, ne. Will.
Weikarlag ist am Start.
Ich muss gucken,
dass ich den Damage irgendwie halbwegs optimiert
kriege.
Action.
Also, Will.
Moment.
Kann man diese Dinger killen,
dass sie nicht explodieren?
Wait a minute.
Hier muss ich speichern, weil
das ist in dem Game
nicht so ganz klar.
Kann ich die killen?
Weil ich weiß nicht, was passiert, wenn ich die
wenn ich die Dinger kaputt mache, ja?
Also entweder,
wenn ich die Dinger anschieße,
explodieren sie oder
sie gehen weg.
Also insofern,
weiß man ja nicht.
Kalag steht auf der Mine
drauf. Ich sehe die nicht.
Kannst du dich bewegen,
please?
Shadowheart steht da eigentlich ganz gut.
Kalag steht auf der Mine, ich kann die nicht anklicken.
Okay, eins,
und jetzt noch
zwei auf den, um auf Nummer sicher zu gehen.
Einer macht
zwei bis fünf, komm.
Scheiß drauf.
Ich muss mal gucken, ob das funktioniert,
so wie ich mir das vorstelle.
Moment, die Minen sind explodiert?
Wait a minute.
Die Minen machen Damage,
wenn man draufschießt.
Und die haben gerade ziemlich gut
die Gegner gebashed.
Hypnotic Pattern
läuft noch in den Zug.
Ja, Geldern,
Geldern war es das hier für dich.
Wir müssen halt Kalag irgendwie
heilen. Hat Will
irgendeinen guten
Dank der mächtigen Heilung.
Okay, Kalag,
du haust jetzt erstmal hier drauf.
Auf den Typ.
In der Hoffnung, dass du keinen Opportunity
Attack auslöst, das sieht ja nicht so aus.
So, wir könnten
Wir müssen die Gegner
killen, geht nicht anders.
Sonst machen die viel zu viel Damage.
2D5
Ach Moment.
Das ist eine Bonusaktion?
Ja, hätte ich das mal gleich gemacht.
Äh Moment.
Ach Shit.
Das haut ja auch noch vorbei.
Okay.
Wir heilen uns mal.
Ein bisschen ist besser als gar nichts.
Und du musst auf jeden Fall
hier raus.
Aus dem Explosionsradius.
Okay, Shadowheart steht
in keinem Explosionsradius drin.
Würde ich sagen.
Chat, was meint ihr?
Meint das Game, dass Shadowheart
in dem Radius steht oder nicht?
Deswegen, ich speichere mal.
Ich save Skamme ja nach Möglichkeit,
aber ich speichere das Game nicht.
So.
Ungültiges Ziel?
Wie jetzt?
Was ist das?
Da ist doch eine Granate.
Ich sehe das doch ganz genau.
Ja.
Okay.
Wenn das nicht geht, dann
Fireball.
Komm Shadowheart, du hältst es aus.
Ach das geht oder was?
Shadowheart.
Viel Erfolg beim Überleben.
Okay. Close.
Die hat Damage von den Minen
bekommen by the way.
Nicht nur vom Fireball.
Glaube ich zumindest.
Okay.
Alles gut.
Du hast schon Damage gemacht.
Kannst du noch irgendwas machen, Will?
Nee.
Also einer von denen geht jetzt auf jeden Fall...
Wer kommt denn jetzt hier dran?
Die da? Die da? Die?
Und bevor Shadow... Okay.
Einer von beiden geht down jetzt, wenn nicht beide.
Dann habe ich ziemlich gelitten.
Moment, warum ist Spirit Guardians
aus eigentlich?
Blöde Frage.
What?
Warum wurden die gerade geheilt?
Egal, Spirit Guardians OP.
Spirit Guardians OP.
Sag ich doch.
Ich will den Dude nicht looten.
Mann, ich will... Game.
Ich will hier hinlaufen, ich will hier nicht looten.
Okay.
Ähm. Close.
Ich meine, wir haben immer noch
1, 2,
3, 4...
Das sind aber nur Level 5er.
Und die stehen da unten in den Minen.
Okay, noch eine Waffe.
Wir stellen uns so hin,
dass die von da oben nicht rankommen.
Dass die runterlaufen müssen.
Ist der Baldur's Gate 3?
Das ist der 4. Baldur's Gate 3 Stream.
Oh, sonst noch irgendwas übrig?
F.
What the fuck?
What is happening?
Ich bin jetzt
in einer kleinen Zwickmühle, Leute.
Ja, warum?
Ich habe Damage bekommen von den Minen.
Ich war doch überhaupt nicht in Range.
Ich bin jetzt in einer kleinen Zwickmühle.
Ich kann die Gegner
doppelt Fireballen.
Und hoffen...
Oh, mein Shadowheart ist dead.
Ne, so.
Ich kann die Gegner doppelt Fireballen.
Und hoffen, dass ich sie kille.
Was gar nicht so unwahrscheinlich ist.
Die haben nicht so viel...
So viel Leben.
Oder ich habe...
Oder ich heile meine Leute.
Die Sache ist die, wenn ich meine Leute heile...
Okay, ich weiß,
was wir machen.
Wir machen... Nein, nein, nein.
Wir machen das Five-Head-Play, Leute.
Will?
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob es frunzt.
Wir machen das...
Ne, es frunzt nicht.
Ich sollte es richtig machen.
Ich wollte es nämlich sagen.
Wir können
Kalag unsichtbar machen.
Wir können die Gegner auch versuchen,
zu...
C10.
Okay, ich glaube, das ist
das safere Play.
Versuchen die Gegner zu C10.
In der Hoffnung, wir erwischen möglichst viele.
Will belebt Kalag wieder.
Full Damage.
Okay, wir probieren es.
Weil ihr es seid, Chat. Wir probieren Full Damage.
Die sind immun gegen Feuerschaden.
Alles klar?
Ich dachte, die sind nur resistent
gegen Feuerschaden.
Ja, das ist ja...
Da machen wir Chebaded, der Chat.
Aber seit wann sind die immun?
Eben waren die doch noch nur resistent.
Muss man das nachvollziehen können?
Ja, die sind resistent. Die sind nicht immun.
Moment.
Die waren doch vorher noch nicht immun, oder?
Die waren doch vorher nur resistent?
Ha.
Okay.
Das ist dumm.
Das ist wirklich schlecht.
Wie komme ich denn aus der Sache raus?
Ich habe kein AE-Damage.
Okay, wir hatten doch Dimensionstor.
Okay, wir probieren mal was.
Ah, das ist das falsche.
Ich will...
Ach, geil, Alter.
Okay.
Wir verpissen uns jetzt einfach und heilen erst mal.
Beste Idee.
Ich meine, die Dinger können vielleicht da hoch, aber...
Nein!
Ich wollte den werfen!
Shit!
QI. Liegt nicht an mir.
Muss am Game liegen.
Ich wollte den werfen und nicht...
Das ist ja doof.
Okay, wir machen einfach genau das gleiche nochmal.
Okay, geil.
Runterhüpfen.
Dimensionstor casten.
Und hochteleportieren.
Will.
Welcher Taste? F8.
Eiltrunk.
So, und jetzt hoffe ich mal...
Haben wir hier noch einen Eiltrunk?
Ah, cool.
Das ist schon mal gut.
Die werfen keine Bomben jetzt auf mich.
Wenn die jetzt Bomben auf mich werfen, bin ich...
extrem gefickt.
Ah, gibt nichts mehr.
Ja, ja, ist gut.
Geht ihr alle auf Spiritual Weapon.
Nein, nein, nein, lasst Shadowheart in Ruhe.
Shadowheart in Ruhe lassen.
Alles gut.
Lasst sie in Ruhe.
Okay.
Ich habe keinerlei Spells, man.
Kann ich irgendwas killen hiervon?
Vielleicht wenigstens.
Okay, nice.
Okay, geil.
Geil.
Du musst Shadowheart saven noch.
Ist Will?
Falscher Charakter ausgewählt.
Gleiches Bett getimed.
Aber den Fight machen wir noch.
Echt, geht das?
Lass mich demonstrieren.
Es ist alligator, Nico.
Dann, ja doch, komm, scheiß drauf.
Alligator ordentlich.
Haben wir eine sinnvolle Bonusaktion noch als Pala?
Gut, Will, du kannst ein bisschen Schaden machen an den Gegnern noch.
An einem von denen hier.
Der ist doch fast down.
Okay, den da und den da.
Einer down.
Ich habe halt keine Zauber,
die denen groß Damage machen können.
Das da vielleicht.
Sind die auch gegen Gift immun?
Scheiß, Alter.
Ich habe keine Spells.
Das muss...
Radiant Damage, ja.
Shadowheart Radiant Damage höchstens.
Ist aber auch echt das einzige.
Shit, man.
Ja, mach Damage auf das Ding.
Sehr gut, mach auf das Ding Damage.
Sehr gut, perfekt.
Ja, gut, nice.
So, Shadowheart hat...
Jawoll.
Hier, noch ein Spiritual Weapon hier.
Gib ihm.
Lass die mal ein bisschen
da drauf rumhauen, das ist schon gut.
So, Shadowheart kann die Runde nichts machen.
Shadowheart versteckt sich mal kurz,
dass sie kein Damage bekommt.
Ja, ist gut.
Haut ihr da nur drauf.
Wunderbar.
Es wäre cool, wenn das Ding überleben würde.
Was es auch macht.
Ach nee, macht es nicht.
So.
Also.
Gale CCt die.
Und wir gucken mal,
inwieweit das klappt.
Also Feuer macht nicht genug Schaden.
Kalec muss runter und muss die bashen.
Anders geht es nicht.
Hm.
Moment, hat Will noch?
Will kann die CCn.
Ja, dann machen wir das doch so.
Gale hastet.
Ja, Gale hastet.
Kalec.
Und dann.
Okay, probieren wir das mal aus.
Will.
Hoffentlich tut das.
Ja, ja, die meisten.
Zwei Stück nicht, aber das ist okay.
Gale hastet auf.
Kalec.
Und die gibt jetzt.
Hm.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das funzt.
Nein, nein, nein.
Da bin ich mir jetzt nicht sicher,
wie das funktioniert.
Weil.
Ich würde mich gerne noch mal heilen vorher.
Ich müsste genug Aktionen haben.
Guck mal, die sind alle hypnotisiert.
Außer der Dude.
So.
Passiv ist aus.
So, ich würde mich gerne noch mal heilen vorher.
Ich hoffe, ich kann danach weiter ordentlich angreifen.
Ich bin ja hastet, das sollte funktionieren.
Oh, 40%, Alter.
Das ist mir zu schlecht.
Haben wir sonst irgendwas,
was wir machen können? Ne.
Okay.
Wir müssen jetzt hoffen, dass Kalec
dir irgendwie bashen kann.
Oh, das wird nichts.
Ohne Spell Slots
für Radiant Damage.
Na gut.
Gale, du kannst eh nichts machen jetzt.
Du kannst dich hier neben Shadowheart verstecken.
Will, du konzentrierst dich.
Du kannst auch nichts machen.
Du kannst dich auch verstecken gehen.
Okay, der kann nur einmal hauen und sonst nichts.
Äh, zweimal hauen.
Ja, okay, easy.
Okay, Shadowheart, vielleicht kannst du dir ein bisschen
Damage machen.
Ah, Shadowheart
hat auch das hier.
Das benutzen wir.
Wir lassen Kalec dir ein bisschen
Damage machen. Am Ende kann Shadowheart
die noch wegblasten.
Sofern das möglich ist.
Wir haben noch zwei Spell Slots.
Vielleicht haben wir Glück.
Und wir hitten.
Natürlich nicht.
Gut, aber Shadowheart kann
mal hier rüber gehen.
Die schon ein bisschen näher dran
ist.
Okay, die können alle nichts machen.
Sehr schön.
Aber der CC hält halt nicht mehr lange
und ich hab keinen mehr.
Gale, hast du irgendwas?
Okay, Magic Missile.
Das ist das einzige, was irgendwie noch
Damage macht.
Können auch keine Spells mehr recovern.
Oh, shit.
Okay, Magic Missile ist das einzige, was irgendwie Schaden macht.
Ich mach mal nur auf
eins, weil
vielleicht brauch ich noch ein Misty Step.
Ja, das war ein ganz guter Hit.
Du machst den jetzt dead.
Hoffentlich.
Hoffentlich machst du den dead.
Du machst den dead. Sehr schön.
Will, gut gemacht.
Du kannst nicht wirklich sagen,
Wellendox, dass es
Gale nicht gerissen hat.
Er hat zwar nicht viel Damage gemacht,
aber das Porten,
das CC'n, also
ohne das hätte es nicht funktioniert.
Was haben wir denn hier noch?
Avernus.
Dann hauen wir das Viech hier raus.
Ich hoffe, ich hitte.
Ja.
Oh, das hat gut Schaden gemacht.
Okay, komm, YOLO.
YOLO Attack, 40%.
Dafür mehr Damage.
Jawoll.
Sehr schön.
11, 8, es ist fast down.
So, die müssten eine Runde noch hypnotisiert sein,
wenn ich Glück habe.
Oh, shit.
Au.
Okay, kann Shadowheart
den vielleicht sogar
killen?
Shadowheart macht noch eine
Spiritual Weapon hier unten hin.
Und jetzt
macht sie den letzten Spell Slot Prager,
dass er stirbt.
Sehr schön.
Okay, Leute, ich glaube,
wir gewinnen das noch.
Die sind nämlich noch, diese Runde
CCed, sehr nice.
Okay, jetzt sollten wir es bloß
nicht verkacken,
weil wir können die immer noch
immer noch richtig gut Damage machen.
Wie lang ist denn der?
Der Range ist nicht so lang.
Wir bringen Shadowheart mal hier vor.
Guck mal, die sind nämlich alle raus
jetzt.
Wait a minute, das geht nicht.
Man kann das hier nicht runter machen,
das heißt, Shadowheart muss nächste Runde hier runter
hüpfen, okay.
Das ist ein bisschen blöd,
aber okay.
Dann
gibt Shadowheart
einfach Advantage.
Das ist, glaube ich, das
Beste, was sie jetzt machen
kann.
Okay.
Der hat wenig Leben.
Jetzt haben wir Advantage.
Okay, damit sollten wir den richtig gut bashen können.
Wir haben unsere Passive Damage
Add an.
Und noch
Elf, ja, ein Treffer noch, dann dead.
Und weil
sie Hasted ist, nochmal extra Damage.
Oh, was habe ich denn hier noch?
Bonus Aktion.
Deine Waffenangriffe
wirken zusätzlich
und können deine Ziele
ein... Ach, das ist gut.
Das machen wir jetzt noch.
Nee, das machen wir nicht vorher.
Wir hauen den jetzt nochmal
und dann kriegt
der mit der Rückseite
von der Waffe nochmal einen drauf.
Ja, viel
besser. Fast
dead.
Dann kann Gale eventuell
finishen.
Elf, ja.
Okay, das sollte mit Magic
Missile Stufe 2
hinhauen.
Dead.
Okay, also ein Gegner,
ein Level 5er, den sollten wir mit
vier Leuten doch noch
hinbekommen.
Okay, Will, gebe ihm.
Sehr schön.
Und jetzt kommt noch die Spiral Weapon drauf.
Fehlenschlag, na gut.
Wow!
Ich habe schon gedacht, ihr wirft mich wieder runter.
Sau, ey.
Die Sau.
Leute, wir haben es geschafft.
Oh!
Und wir haben nicht gesaved skummt.
Wir haben nur geladen, als sie mich
zweimal unglaublich sinnlos verklickt haben
mit dem Charakter.
Alter!
Das war
nicht ohne.
Okay, einmal kurz Short Rest.
Oh, looten
muss noch gelootet werden.
Richtiger Macher.
Genau so, Hand, Arm, Brust.
Juckt mich nicht.
Das Metall, das ist gut für Kalec.
Wer ist inspiriert?
Ich habe jetzt nicht hingeguckt.
Irgendeiner ist inspiriert.
Helle Bade.
Oh, großes
Elementarbeschwören.
Das ist Porke.
Wobei das auch
echt gefährlich sein kann, wenn man
Konzentration verliert, greifen die einen an.
Falls das in Baldur's Gate 3
auch so ist.
Mitnehmen tue ich die Armbrust eh.
Aber ich glaube, ich habe niemanden, der das wirklich gescheit tragen kann.
Will ist etwas überladen.
Wohin habe ich den gar nicht gelootet?
Den habe ich noch nicht gelootet.
Kann das sein?
Das ist einfach nur eine blöde Anzeige, oder?
Dass ich den nicht gelootet habe.
Der Spell der Armbrust
ist gut, zeigt mal her.
Aha.
Bewirkt, möglicherweise
brennend, wenn du eine Kreatur mit dieser Waffe triffst,
während du versteckt oder unsichtbar bist.
Das ist irgendwas,
du stellst da.
Ich weiß es noch nicht.
Könnt ihr da nicht auch runterhüpfen jetzt?
Ihr könnt doch hier runterhüpfen, alle.
Es sieht nichts, doch können sie.
Geht doch.
Wie kann das sein, dass der Ober...
Das ist eine gute Frage,
weil ich keine Rogues und
Schleicher gerne spiele,
indem die
ans Lager senden.
Gut.
Leute.
Richtig mega anstrengender Fight.
Gab aber bestimmt fett XP.
Ja, wir sind fast Level 9. Morgen Level 9.
Anstrengende Sache. Easy Clap.
Schön, dass ihr dabei gewesen seid.
Ich gehe jetzt pennen.
Morgen spielen wir nicht weiter.
Morgen muss ich auf jeden Fall
mein Video hochladen.
Und erstmal schneiden und hochladen.
Und dann basteln wir ein bisschen.
Ich bin mir noch nicht ganz sicher, ob wir basteln
am Samstag oder am Sonntag.
Aber jetzt ist Bedgetime.
Wir sehen uns. Chat.
Bis morgen.
Macht's gut. See you.
Schön, dass so viele geguckt haben.
Und wenn das nicht die Vieweranzahl
der normalen Streams ist, macht das gar nichts.
Finde das schön, dass trotzdem Leute auch beim
Gaming-Stream von nicht ganz so Mainstreamigen
...
Naja, doch. Kann man schon sagen.
Eigentlich ziemlich Mainstreamigen Games dabei sind.
Alles klar. Bis morgen. Macht's gut. See you.